all right welcome to a very special
edition of beginner breakdown I'm
Jonathan trance I'm filling in for Mike
comer once again due to the inclement
weather my comer was not yeah gonna be
able to join us tonight he's got his his
big truck can't drive on the ice so it
also we got a little bit lighter class
but we got her our true and loyal fans
are here they came out braving the
weather so yes thanks for everybody that
came today we're gonna go over games
over one of our staff members he's
somebody that works only on Tuesdays his
name is Andrew Young and he's gonna have
a baby so by the time you see this he
might already have a baby so a big
congrats in advance and we'll go over
some of his games I don't think he has a
u.s. CF rating but uh we'll see his
strength he's probably about fourteen
hundred twelve hundred I don't know
somewhere in there so we'll take a look
at this this first game was a game that
I played against him we were just
playing on chess calm there's a
correspondence game so we had three days
per move or something like that and most
of it was played during just during work
hours so let's see what happened I
decided to play d4 because we had just
recently I was when I did my note boom
left sure so I figured maybe well he'll
play into that he mentioned something
about it and he started to do that
scepter d5 c4 he supported the center
with a pawn so now we have a Slav
defense and okay one thing you can do is
you can play Knight to c3 but I played
Knight to f3 hoping to encourage him to
play the move east six which would be
the note boom in a lecture that we went
into after something like this I was
just gonna play Knight to c3 and hope
that he takes on c4 and then tries to
protect his pawn and alright I just done
a lecture on it and I think he was
talking about it so that's what I was
hoping for but he did something a little
different he played the main line here
and if you're worried about black taking
on c4 you could play III here but I
played the main move Knight to c3 and
now black has a couple moves in this
position he can play the Slav just by
taking on c4
a six is a move g6 is a move but he
played a move that I like to play a lot
as black as well the semi Slav and here
white has two different moves he can get
his his Bishop out which is the most
aggressive and you could play III which
is solid and in most lines White has a
pretty nice very slight but a nice
little advantage and here is the man of
the hour in the audience yeah I take it
I take a good look at that guy okay so I
brought my bishop out in here there's a
couple different things that black can
do he played what's not you know the the
most testing Bishop to e7 when you play
Bishop to e7 this is kind of like a
Queens gambit declined only you've
already determined that your pawn was
going to c6 and normally in that the
Queens gambit declined you're trying to
play the move c5 all in one go so here
it's kind of already a tempo loss and
that's kind of how it the game panned
out okay also possible is the much
crazier and more aggressive grabbing of
the pond and this can lead to the
bottleneck system after okay white plays
energetically black defends the pond and
now he five and it looks like well we're
you attacked your your pin piece what
you're not gonna do what move does black
have to play here because yeah you can't
move your your knight
because then you lose your queen h6 yes
after a move like h6 the main line goes
you drop your Bishop back and after g5
Dany Machuca is the only one that knows
what white plays here
yeah Knight takes g5 sacrificing this
piece and just to give you a little idea
of how crazy these lines get well what's
eventually going to regain the piece
when he takes on f6 so the main line
will go like this you want to be sure if
they you don't want them to be able to
capture with a bishop without losing his
bishop and all right we won't really go
over this this isn't the theme of the
lecture let's uh let's take that guy and
all right so stuff like this tends to
happen and we'll get some crazy position
and here's okay one of the craziest and
wildest
and chess and I bring it up just to
mention the possibilities and both sides
try to checkmate each other and material
means nothing in these lines it's all
about active pieces and checkmating and
lots of wild and crazy possibilities
okay but ain't didn't go in for the
crazy stuff Bishop e7 and even though it
is like the Queens gambit declined with
tempo down because you know if you're
ever gonna play c5 in the future it's
like you lost the tempo it's not all
that easy to refute and it's not like
suddenly White has you know some winning
move or anything so I just played
normally I put my pawn on e3 now at some
time I can get my Bishop out and my
bishop is defending my pawns so if he
ever takes it now I can just simply
recapture with my Bishop and here he
developed a piece makes sense and now I
waited to get my Bishop out I played
Queen to c2 and the reason I didn't you
know just immediately bring my bishop
out is black is usually waiting but
before he takes on c4 for white to make
a bishop move that way when you play the
move D takes c4 and I take back with a
bishop I had to use two bishop moves to
play the same move so here I'm waiting
and okay we'll see in the game he
eventually took before I had to waste a
move which was to my advantage so
alright he attacked my bishop so I
dropped back and here yeah I think he
should Castle instead he took on c4 so
he didn't wait for me if he castles and
then I moved my bishop to one of these
squares and then he takes some c4 now
it's this position but you know it's his
turning again so that would cost me a
little bit of time so probably if he
castled I would try to delay moving my
bishop for as long as possible I might
play a move like rook to d1 and I'm just
waiting but okay but if we go back he
took on c4 right away so now I get to
take back with the bishop and okay he
plays this move which is very similar
it's it's like he's playing the Queens
gambit declined here and white has a
choice now should he trade the bishops
or show do you retreat back to g3 and I
couldn't really tell what was best I
assumed maybe taking was objectively a
little bit stronger but I thought you
know I'm I'm the higher ed player I'm
the one that's this plan for a win here
I thought I'd keep as many pieces on the
board as possible and the bishop is
Knight nice on g3 black will have a hard
time in the future ever breaking with E
5 and Black has to get one of these
breaks in either a5 or c5 to get a good
position otherwise he's gonna be stuck
with this Bishop and we'll see that in a
lot of these games today he gets stuck
with a bad bishop and he never gets it
free so ok castled castled and now here
what did I do okay here I just brought a
rook to the D file again I'm just trying
to dissuade him from any of these breaks
well I really got a 5 under control
because I got a pawn a knight a bishop
everyone's protecting it but I'm trying
to dissuade him from playing the move c5
because if he does that I have a rook on
the same file as this Queen so if he
does this I can just simply take here
and then you know if you take back some
bad things would happen based on the
fact that okay there's a pin here so
stuff like this I'm just trying to
prevent him from playing c5 so that's
why I brought my rook into the game and
okay he broke one of my rules here never
play Bishop to d7 and okay I tell all of
my students that and in some positions
right like with every rule there's a
reason that you might want to break it
but here's a classic example of when you
shouldn't play Bishop to d7 so the point
is you the problem is he wants to
develop this bishop it's obvious that
this is the next piece that he needs to
get out so he needs to find a way to get
his Bishop loose it's unlikely that he's
ever gonna play e5 and get his Bishop
out this way because I got a five really
under control so he should probably try
to get his Bishop out in the other
direction so he can play either b6 or b5
and get his Bishop on the longer
diagonal here this is typically where
this Bishop will end up going the bishop
it just doesn't belong on d7 and all
right now I played a move that in
hindsight I regret slightly only
slightly I did something which violates
the rule never do anything right that's
the biggest secret in chess is yeah
don't do anything black lacks a
constructive plan here so I should
probably just play the move like h3 we
in the future I allowed him to put his
night on h.5 and take my bishop so I
should play let me play h3 and then I
have a square to move my bishop back to
instead I did something I pushed in the
center so okay I'm I figured okay you're
played Bishop d7 I'm gonna do something
now and what's he gonna do he's probably
gonna take my knight and it's a very
pleasant position I have a really nice
Center but I did allow him to go and get
my bishop so so I was thinking all right
instead of just you know making some
legal move and then you get to take my
bishop
I brought my Bishop on e5 to provoke a
weakness I'm hoping after he plays the
move f6e six will become a target and
yeah later on that's indeed what
happened f6 is probably not you know a
terrible move at all but it gives me a
little bit something I can work with
here and he took so okay now if it's
it's my turn you know I might be
thinking about playing to move like
Queen to b3 with a double attack so
alright he protected his beep on and I
went ahead with it anyway so forcing his
his queen to make another move if she
wants to protect upon notice that uh
yeah you pretty much have to protect
with your queen
what will White play in this variation
like why can't you just protect with a
king that looks safe enough your queen
gets to stay where she is
but wait here actually has a really good
move that I was planning on playing and
I'll give you a hint we really want to
break open this diagonal so we're yeah
we really want to get this guy out of
the way
yeah pawn to d5 and now yeah if this
this diagonal never opens up it's a it's
only gonna be pleasant for me and yeah
the King will be kind of in trouble
I'm just threatening to like push so or
you know take something depending on
what he does so that would actually be
really dangerous for black so he played
correctly he defended with the Queen and
now I have to kind of come up with an
idea I realized that black is probably
gonna play the move like b5 so I could
consider you're playing a move like a
for the line that I saw in my head that
I didn't go in for was if he does play
this move here I realized okay I can win
a pawn but now I was I was worrying that
because the B file is open he's able to
pin my piece so I thought okay I'd have
to play a move like c4 and then I
thought he can play move like a6
attacking my pinned piece but actually I
have a good move here and I was just
doing this in my head I kind of realized
okay at the end of this line maybe my e
pawn will be hanging but White has a
move to save himself here Bishop to a4
so threatening to trade Queens the Queen
doesn't have time to take so okay so I
this would be my saving move here but I
didn't go in for this I thought okay he
can play the move b5 if he wants
I played a five I'm just trying to lock
down this pawn here that's gonna be the
weakness I'm gonna try to target for the
rest of the game and okay now I'm
thinking okay he did kick my bishop away
and so I have to retreat somewhere so
there's you know three candidate moves
that I might pick from and okay I think
Bishop to d3 and Bishop to e2
we're the only two to really consider
and I'm thinking now of a LightSquared
strategy the reason is I have a
LightSquared bishop so I'm hoping I can
somehow take advantage of all these
weakened light squares around this King
so I had to determine how I wanted my
bishop to enter the game today I want my
bishop to go to d3 and enter these light
squares eetu and then enter the light
squares over here I ended up choosing
Bishop to e2 my plan is I'm gonna put my
knight on h4 and I'm gonna bring my
bishop in and
to jump into these light squares that's
where I'm gonna you know focus my my
pieces here okay a five and again I
might consider a move like a four but I
chose to get on with my strategy here
and I'm just gonna plunk a knight in
here alright so he used his his King to
prevent my knight from coming in I
wanted to get my bishop into the game so
I got to do that anyway and now I can
put a piece on g6 so this was my my big
strategy here he kicks my queen away so
okay I thought the most logical place
was C - my queen also can enter on the
light squares and he blocked with f5 so
at some moment I'm probably gonna
consider the move g4u attacking the
light squares with my pawns that's my my
big focus every move I'm gonna do
something on the light squares here but
first I decided I jump my knight in and
it is kind of annoying for black because
okay if you move your Bishop your yoke
is hanging so you have to move your rook
and protect your bishop but either
square you go to will leave you
susceptible to some discovered attacks
so he went here and at the moment of my
choosing I can move my knight away and
I'll be attacking your rook which is you
know just kind of a little annoying
threat this in the position but I didn't
do it for it right away
I played g4 so yeah again I'm even using
my pawns to attack the light squares
here and I might take it on f5 at the
the right moment so okay so yeah he got
his King off that diagonal it was a was
a pretty scary diagonal and I did indeed
take here okay now I decided to jump my
knight back I'm attacking his rook and
now he moved and now somehow my big
advantage in a you know in this position
is I got a lot of pawns in the center so
like these two they're gonna have to win
the day for me somehow I'm gonna have to
get these sorts of moves in and get my
pawns rolling in the center so here I
played a tricky move Bishop to f3 and to
demonstrate my big idea here if we pass
for black I'll just make a a null move
here my point was I'm gonna play the
move D
five and you know I'm trying to get
these pawns rolling and you can't take
here because now after this check I get
to pick up your rook and okay so that's
that was my tricky way to get to play
the move d5 and in the game I get did
get to play d5 and so that was just good
for me probably you should just move
your your rook over or something or
somehow just get off of that diagonal so
that d5 doesn't make the same threats
okay but he brought his Bishop over to
g5 and okay so I'm so I'm thinking this
bishop when I was here was controlling
this long diagonal here so I go back to
d3 and I'm thinking at just the right
moment I might be able to jump into c5
so now that the bishop is kind of on an
adventure over here I think your Bishop
was really belonged here so you could
prevent my Knight from going to these
squares but okay and then he did go back
so is that is that an improvement for
him should I go back to f4 and make a
draw well now my my big positional
threat does come to be realized I played
to move d5 and yeah so this is favorable
so now these guys are very very strong
and I'm gonna push them down the board
and so once more you can't take because
I check and then I win the rook okay so
he had to play some other move f4 maybe
g5 is a little more bit more testing but
either way I'm pushing these pawns so I
have four and okay I pushed now his
bishop has to make a decision here which
way should it go and he went to g5 I
think because my night is really
planning on using one of these dark
squares that your bishop should instead
go to d8 that way if I ever put a night
here at the right moment you can contest
my knight and kick my knight away so yes
I think your your bishop went to the
wrong diagonal there okay so I did
indeed put my knight there I'm
protecting this square the next pawn
move that I gotta make is e6 so I have
to protect that square enough time so
that I can push my pawns and it's
difficult for him because you'll notice
it's
hard to ever use this rook to prevent me
from playing the movie six because I can
always you know attack it and there's
there's nowhere safe to go so okay
so he played wrote a seven and now I'm
trying to get the movie six in so I got
defend that square one more time and now
I'm ready to push my pawns okay and okay
the idea of blockading makes sense but
here it's it's a it's a big blunder it
loses at least upon and maybe it's even
worse than that so I took he took back
and then there was two moves that were
really tempting here taking on c6 is
perhaps the most obvious and that's what
I played in the game the other move I
was tempted to play was Bishop to g4 not
going for material but simply asking
your queen where she's gonna go and I
realized there's not a lot of places she
can go if she goes to c4 I can take her
and then you have really weak pawns I
can go around this guy up at the right
moment if you go anywhere else let's see
this is a safe square for the moment
okay I'm gonna keep pushing and my pawns
are gonna be rolling down really fast
and same with here I might just just
keep pushing so that was tempting just
you know getting the Queen off the
square that I need to push my pawns so
but I ended up taking here and then he
missed the threat which was unfortunate
so he played rook to f5 and not only am
I thinking about just munching up all
these pawns I also had another threat in
this position so what was the final move
that I played here yeah Bishop to d5
okay and he resigned so the queen is
pinned to the king here and all right
with the fact that I'm about to win a
lot of material and these guys are still
going to keep coming he gave it up here
so yeah I was interesting this game
there's a couple like inaccuracies out
of the opening that helped me to get a
really nice position and then the fact
that I provoked some weaknesses on the
light squares really helped me out in
the long run okay
all right so we'll take a look at
another game here and we'll look at it
from Andrews perspective this is a game
he played on the internet against one of
his his old coaches so all right I'm not
online his coaches rated twenty to
thirty one at the time in this game so
not not too shabby and okay it looked
like he he played like the stronger
player so we'll take a look at this one
all right now okay an opening then I'm
not particularly fond of in this
position I think the move C takes d5 is
just a very very good position for white
and I've won a lot of games this way
with white and it's just a good position
if black intends to play the green field
he should probably play the move g6 and
only after Knight to c3 play d5 and one
of the main reasons is in this position
if they play the exchange variation
which is common enough and you play e4
now black has the option of taking this
night and okay
and then he's gonna try to undermine the
center in the future he's gonna get all
his pieces to attack the center and
because white has such a big center it's
in blacks best interest to trade as many
pieces as possible to nullify the effect
of the center when white has all his
pawns in the center sometimes it's hard
for black to find good squares for all
of his pieces so it's a to whites
advantage to keep as many pieces on the
board in this position as possible now
in that the game he played d5 first so
now if you capture and the Knight takes
back and you play the movie for well now
there's no option of taking on c3
so this Knight will either go to f6 or
b6 and now you can bring your night out
to c3 and you don't have to worry about
you know exchanging one of the pieces
keeping an extra piece on the board is
in White's best interest so I would
prefer this way as white instead Knight
to c3 which is of course a no means a
bad move at all it's just a logical move
so okay alright and now we've transposed
back into a Grune field and then okay so
white has quite a lot of moves here you
know Knight f3 Bishop f4 Bishop G
five queen bee three is even a move so
there's a lot of different moves here
but kind of like what we saw in the last
game he played III and this guy gets
kind of trapped in so in general you
want to get this guy outside of the pawn
chain so both of these moves are
interesting and you know you could be
considered before you play the movie
three because then your Bishop gets to a
good square so for the moment this guy
is just sitting there idly all right
and so but just makes a logical move and
Andrew chose a unique setup here most
common is just playing Knight f3 the
knight is the next most logical piece
you want to develop your Knights before
your bishops in general and okay so
that's just a move that makes sense
instead Bishop to d3 and it's he's gonna
put his knight here on e too and we'll
see how well that works out so black
gets castled and so the knight does not
go to f3 it goes to e2 now in some
positions the reason you might want to
put a night on e 2 is you're gonna play
F 3 and E 4 but that's generally only
gonna work if the position is very
closed here black can open the position
at any time and he can you know trade
more threats in the center and so in the
Grune felled typically the center is
gonna be wide open and this is the kind
of game that black is playing for so
this kind of setup here wasn't the best
it would have been better if the knight
went to the normal square and maybe the
bishop was on e too so all right and
black responds appropriately the way to
take advantage of this this poor setup
is to open up the center as much as
possible that'll also unleash this guy
the more more pawns you get out of the
way the stronger that bishops gonna
become and so he castled and we got some
captures so stuff is gonna be opening up
and he took with the pawn if you take
with the knight black can get a nice
position okay you can kick the night
away and just play like Knight to c6
something like this would be really
pleasant for him the okay diagnose wide
open in general he wants to keep a pawn
in the center so that was played and his
opponent took on c4 and when he takes
back now he has an
Queen pond which isn't so bad and itself
always but in these positions the
compensation that white is looking for
when he has an IQ P is really active
pieces in a big attack so it makes sense
if his night was over here maybe could
go to e5 and maybe his pieces were in
better places to attack the black King
but here there's no real attack and
we'll see you black did it was a really
nice demonstration of how to fight
against the DI QP here so okay so he's
putting some pressure on the center h3
okay probably not a developing move when
you have the isolate upon you really
want to get your pieces out as fast as
possible so maybe there was a bitter
square we could find for this Bishop but
h3 was played now to move ecigs it's
possible to stay a little bit more
flexible you know you can play like a
six and B five
but e6 has its points he's trying to
take control over the d5 square and so
when you're fighting against an AI QP
what you need to do is first control d5
that's step one of the three-step
process and then step two is you can
blockade on d5 maybe one of these nights
can jump in here and control the square
and then lastly the third step is you
can begin to attack the pawn you know
you can imagine some wherever the
Queen's are and get your rooks and you
can get some pieces attacking the pawn
and so we see a nice demonstration here
okay the bishop goes to e3 and his
intention with this move is he's gonna
put the Bishop on b7 where it controls
d5 and okay after he attacks the knight
but a black intended to protect move his
Bishop there anyway so all right Rokon
d1 makes sense and now we we see it so
one of these pieces is going to jump in
here to d5 and by blockading that square
black has a really really pleasant
position alright so the knight on f4
this is useful for blockading and he
might sometimes have sacrificial ideas
as in the game okay with a threat so
he's got to move one of his pieces and
yet here anyone in
for a sacrificial move here Bishop takes
a six not the only choice I mean he
could have retreated and black actually
gets a pleasant position after one of
two moves the game is the safest it's so
it's it's understandable that it was
played also interesting is the move g5
just look you know not taking the bishop
back right away but now he's attacking
to pieces so in in such a position the
bishop would probably have to give
itself up and now you can take back one
of two ways if you take with the rook I
mean maybe this Knight is jumping in and
you don't really want to lose your your
dark-squared bishop
so also possible is taking with the king
and if you play Knight to e6 I do intend
to take it I don't think you'll ever
have don't be too much danger on this
diagonal because I can blockade and I'll
I'll have to run my King back but yeah
so so that was also interesting to move
g5 taking is of course the safest though
and alright welcome welcome
all right so we got a fork so he's gonna
win like at least an exchange back and
so in this position White has two pawns
for the exchange so materials
theoretically equal but you'll notice
the difference in strength of the pieces
black has this Knight d5 the nice d5
outpost for his knight and he's more in
position to attack the White King than
white is to attack the black King so
just in general black is a little bit
better here just because he has the
better pieces so okay this check and
it's interesting sometimes just because
I noticed there's a check here it's nice
to have a check in reserve you know the
King probably wants to go to h8 so you
help them out you might want to wait to
it's an inopportune time like maybe when
this guy is not defended and you'd be
able to check and like pick up a pawn so
I kind of like to sometimes keep checks
in reserve but it's it's by no means you
know the the worst move here and all
right white gets his last piece into the
game and black here has a serious threat
that was overlooked okay so let's see
after a three
Black has a winning continuation here so
we'll we'll see if the audience can find
it cuz Black has a lot of good pieces
the rook the bishop this night I mean
this guy is kind of useful the Queen
let's draw a lot of scary arrows so what
is that what's the first move here with
a black play what's that how long do we
have
as long as it takes you to solve it all
right now give I'll give the answer away
he took this bishop which okay now after
the F pawn takes will notice this F pawn
is no longer defending the G 3 square so
now black is in control of G 3 and the
Queen gets to slip in and this is very
very dangerous for white okay the
biggest threat is checkmate also hanging
is the e pawn so what does he to do well
he probably should just bring his queen
back and yeah your senator is gonna fall
apart but uh in the game now after this
move black just has a a matin to and
it's it's pretty interesting so it is
based on the fact that yeah these are
our key players you shut this guy down
for the minute but we don't need him to
find that the winning move here so it's
it's a very nice move that will move
that was played in the game we'll see if
our audience can find it and you can
pause your video at home and see if you
can find it it's black to move and win
rook to f2 alright this this also looks
very very good how do I survive it's not
looking not looking good for white yeah
all right there's presumably more than
one way to win here the game yeah I mean
blacks position is just so good there's
there's a lot of great options I like
this move it's just sort of a silent
move and there's no way to stop the
oncoming mate notice the rook just
controlling the whole left file so he
can make one move maybe maybe he won't
see his Queens attacked
and then checkmate end of the game here
so yeah that was just kind of the wrong
setup from the beginning if we just go
back for just a second there was two
things just out of the opening one was
you play d3 and then you had a hard time
finding a good spot for this Bishop
which is kind of the theme of the first
game as well and then yeah this setup
just wasn't quite correct because you
know black was able to open up the
center and then he got a massive attack
and White's pieces weren't very well
coordinated but he doesn't always lose
well we'll end on a high note here this
game is a is a really good one that he
played so alright this is his game
against DB Brooks who I believe is also
a pal of yours
so okay in this game and you guys are
both about the same rating when this
game was played so here we go
so we see d4 again and okay so the same
sort of setup and here his opponent
chose Knight to c3 going maybe for the
veresov or maybe he's going for
something a little different and here
the main move is a Bishop to g5 you know
Bishop f4 is also possible but he went
in for a gambit so he's aiming for the
black more Deemer gambit and when you
take this he's gonna play f3 and he's
gonna make it a true gambit black
doesn't have to except it's possible to
just transpose to a french you know
maybe you'll maybe you can take and
transpose to like a caro-kann or
something so often in this position when
I'm playing somebody that I know really
really wants to play a gambit I just
play the French defense and then they're
like ah you know because when they play
gambits usually they're really really
aggressive players that want to attack
attack attack so if you want to try to
be really positional you can transpose
but this gambit doesn't have a very good
reputation so learning a line or two
that's good against this is also a very
good idea
so if flurry was played and you should
probably accept the gambit and he did
and okay so why would why giveaway upon
like this well he's hoping for really
really fast piece development and an
attack on the black King eventually if
you Castle or just put a rook here the
fact that there
file is open might be pleasant for white
perhaps he can get his Bishop to an
active square
you should get his pieces out really
really quickly well that's not what
happened all right II 6 we see it we see
it yet again it's your favorite thing to
do
yeah the main the main move is actually
Bishop to g4 so yeah yeah get that
Bishop out of there before you play the
movie 6 and all right now a very very
unusual move Bishop to d2 giving me
another chance to prove my rule never
play Bishop to d2 and this again is a
situation where it's really true what
gave up a pawn so he better get a lot of
activity to have compensation so after
this move that doesn't do anything other
than put a bishop in the way it's okay
now black has a very serious advantage
so it's it's very pleasant to be black
now you're up a pond and I mean just
move just makes no sense he should if
he's gonna move his bishop it should
come out to g5 or something and then
play very actively so all right
interesting in this move I think is good
a lot of the times in the black more
Deemer you actually do put the night in
front of the pond just to get a lot of
pressure on d4 so that's typical enough
and you might think this was a mouse
slip oh maybe he maybe he meant to put
his bishop on e3 but it was game in
three days or something like that so
it's this was a long game it wasn't a
1-minute game any mouse slipped so all
right okay and the bishop could have
stayed closer to home often when they
play this line they're gonna get a lot
of pressure so you want to keep some
defenders around your king but this is
by no means a bad move at all and he
gets his Bishop out that's a sensible
enough Square and yeah so now we're
gonna see one of the problems with
having this bishop here is that it's
gonna get attacked so probably he should
try to keep this Bishop and just move it
away but he leaves it there and he
protects it so now when black wants and
maybe he should do it immediately he can
just grab that Bishop before it ever has
a chance to move away but what happened
we canceled and okay so black is
obviously intending to take this bishop
and here he's like you
encouraging you to take it so it's kind
of wasting another tempo and you can't
play a gambit and then waste Tempe left
and right you have to play really
actively and get something going
otherwise you got you got nothing for
your pond that you sacrificed so now he
took so now he's up a pond and has two
bishops so things are looking pretty
good for our protagonist and here he had
a good idea but I think his execution
was a little wrong he wants to play the
move e5 break open the center because
it's this King is still here so that's
you know a pretty good idea you want to
open up the center he played rook to e8
potentially because the F file is open
White's gonna Castle or just put a rope
here and he's gonna get some pressure
along the F on the F file so you might
want to keep your rook here so perhaps
better it was just Queen e7 a good
enough square for the Queen and the rook
is still protecting the F pawn we might
move its ae8 then later but maybe we
won't need to but okay so he intends to
play e5 which is the right idea white
castles and okay he's still preparing
he's gonna do it all right so black yeah
he didn't he didn't never want you to
double the pawns but black was never
really threatening to do that so okay
but yeah he's got to get his pieces to
active squares maybe these Knights are
gonna jump in here create some pressure
on h7 a good decision and now he gets it
in he 5 so excellent c3 so okay
and he took which i think is also an
excellent decision so he didn't move his
bishop right away he inserted this
Intermezzo here and now he's got to take
back one way or the other probably he
doesn't want to isolate his pawn so he
took with the knight and okay there's
more than one thing you can do here but
I kind of like his move here Bishop to
c5 so you're you're not you can't just
take this because notice you're your
queen would be hanging so it's actually
a decent square and he's got a lot of
pressure here on d4 and here's opponent
made the big mistake this sort of
costume
he-hee undefended the d4 square so he
played Bishop to g3
so now black can win another pond he
just takes and okay and so instead of
just taking the knight right away he
grabs a bishop fair enough
and okay so now we're up to pawns we
have a three on two on both sides of the
board so things are looking up all we
have to worry about is a will white get
some sort of attack going because that's
the only thing he has left to play for
but uh okay so uh he was in check he got
out of the way and now there's a lot of
moves black in play yeah the soon this
move is fine yeah I know he helped he
hooked you up now your bishop is good
and in this game he got all of his
pieces two really good squares so that
was excellent
notice the queen is not threatening to
take this pawn due to the hanging the
show and okay and I can choose a lot of
just setups here let's see what happened
b3 yes yeah yeah so this is is a very
very interesting idea is there any way I
can take advantage of the weak back rank
perhaps I can play here my point is if
you grab this either way you grab this
I'm taking here and checkmating you so
you do have to worry about the back rank
if you're gonna move your your rook out
of the way
yeah it's a nice idea but I just assume
after this I don't see well your next
move is here yeah you can swap off
Queens and okay you gave a pawn back and
yeah so I can swap Queens in general I
would say black does not want to
exchange Queens here it's true you know
you can go in there's one idea of
winning this let's put the King here
it's to just trade off the Queen's a
mule that's a that's a fair enough way
to win but it seems like white his King
is a lot less safe than black so if
anything it's gonna be black checkmating
white not the other way around so white
hasn't really shown that he's is
attacking
anything yet so I kind of like this move
yeah not trading the Queens immediately
I don't think that's in his best
interest so b3 that's one way to protect
the pond now he's going to move his rook
into the game and now here he does so
yeah again I don't really particularly
like this move he he can now take and
create a slight structural weakness
you're still winning because you're up
so many pawns but I would prefer to keep
the Queens on the board and there's a
lot of just simple moves black might
want to play one way to use his majority
over here would be to play c6 followed
by a5 a4
that's one way to take advantage of the
fact that your opponent played to move
b3 also you can play the sample move g6
then he'll always have lift and you know
the bishop will be staring right at a
wall but he decides he's gonna trade
Queens and yeah so white should know
okay the Queen's are coming off anyway
he should probably try to get the
positional weakness while he can but
instead he decided to defend this Queen
and let black at the right moment take
the Queen's off the board all right so
we're still have two pawns well it's got
nothing and this technique here was
really good from this point on so yeah
so this is a game that you must be
commended for because this this was well
well played here yeah g6 makes a lot of
sense blunting the bishop and then for
some reason his opponents thinks I'm
gonna attack but uh okay he says no
you're not he's protecting the squares
over here maybe this guy will be a
target in the future and okay so now
he's going after the pond and it's not
very easy to defend so he wanted another
pond so excellent now he's really really
winning what to do all right so all
right so he gets some pressure here
forcing white to have to defend and yeah
very very pleasant for him h5 sure
perhaps he's thinking about H 4 H 3 yeah
he can use either majority he wants to
win this game so offering the trade of
Bishops I mean yeah white just really
can't trade anything here but he's like
RL I'll trade so he takes and then I
quite like this next move
he could you know he might be thinking
I'll just go grab this pawn but he is
allowing white some active play if he
lets him take here so a good decision he
just played the move f5 and this guy is
still gonna be weak for a long time that
guy that weakness is not going away so
why allow your opponent to have any
counter play at all and all right he
moves upon but now you're not gonna be
able to defend these pawns and all right
as soon as I have three I'm 1 on this
side 3 and 1 on this side I think he was
gonna be able to win this game so his
opponent gave it up here so that one was
actually an excellent example once you
were ahead you played really well your
technique was really good which which is
hard for a lot of people sometimes you
get winning positions and you allow too
much counter play and then suddenly oh
you're lost so yeah that was an
excellent display there at the end a
very nice finish